Hi! This is BLACKPINK from South Korea.
We released our Enhanced album in 2020...
...and it was a really interesting opportunity for us...
...because we got to become more personal with our fans.
So instead of just listening to our music,...
...our fans could get their hands on exclusive videos, storylines and canvases...
...and so I think it was a lot of fun for both us and blinks.
So, the concept of the video...
...was to depict two contrasting sides of our group black and pink...
...and so it was a whole lot of fun being two different moods for the day.
Many people use Spotify globally...
...so it helps us reach fans from around the world instantly.
And we were so shocked because we never imagined...
...to have so many people across different countries to listen to our music.
We were really excited to hear that Spotify is finally launching in Korea.
We're glad that our Korean fan will gain access to a larger range of music...
...and provide new artists to share their music to the world.